Oh what happened car poo pourri before
you go twits right okay yeah it's the
spray that makes your [ __ ] not stink so
when people are like that girl thinks
how [ __ ] don't stink you can be like
yeah because I have this thing that
makes it do that ooh oh my god it's oh
my gosh oh my god it's all here [ __ ]
pretty this one has a jewel thing around
it Oh what how does it does that a but
hold charm Burberry party pooper crap a
crap Royal Flush there's so many and
they're under three ounces and I'm about
to get on a plane and Lord knows I'm
taking that with
they were just living around and one was
opening is man trying to open a bottle
of wine without a corkscrew
sorry
me
ha ok this marks the end of fry diary
sorry there wasn't a lot of footage from
today but it's because we filmed our
secret project all day today and it was
so so great I'm in the same clothes as
yesterday you can see because the lost
baggage but look it's here like a lost
child that was pissy and ran away and
decided it has a better life with me
hooray umm secret project is going so
well are gonna continue to shoot all
weekend it's been so fun I now am
resigning myself to my room to edit a
bunch of other secret projects that are
gonna be announced a lot of things are
gonna be announced next week so just
hold on to your bowels until next week
or release them probably release them
that's better don't ever hold on to your
vows I don't know
me at home
I just lost a lot of legs